By now, you've probably heard AI
scientists, Nobel laureates, and even
the godfather of AI himself sounding the
alarm that AI could soon lead to human
extinction. But have you ever wondered
how exactly that could happen? You might
have also heard about AI 2027, a deeply
researched evidence-based scenario
written by AI scientists describing what
could happen over the next few years.
Everyone in AI is talking about it from
industry pioneers to world leaders. And
I'll break it down for you. There are
two endings, a happy ending and a
nightmare ending. Let's go. Open Brain
releases their new AI personal
assistant. It handles complex tasks like
book me a trip to Japan. The agents are
impressive in theory and in cherrypicked
examples, but they're unreliable in
practice. Social media is filled with
stories of tasks bungled in particularly
entertaining
[Music]
ways. Open Brain makes a fateful
decision. They refocus their entire
operation toward creating AIs that can
do AI research. To fuel this goal, they
break ground on the world's biggest
computing cluster, one that requires
1,000 times more processing power than
what was used to train GBT4. Their logic
is simple. If AI itself can accelerate
AI development, creating thousands of
automated researchers who can work
endlessly without breaks, progress won't
just increase, it will explode. The
strategy pays off. Their new creation,
Agent 1, vastly outperforms its earlier
public prototype version and is
particularly good at AI research. This
shows how much AI itself is speeding up
AI progress compared to a baseline of
human researchers. Open Brain Leaprogs
both its American rivals and China's
deep scent. Despite these advances,
OpenBrain safety team harbors doubts
about their apparent progress. Has Agent
One internalized honesty as a core
value? Or merely learn to say what
researchers want? Without mechanistic
interpretability, the ability to read an
AI's mind, they can't be certain. Their
concerns intensify as Agent One shows
troubling behaviors, occasionally lying
to researchers and sometimes hiding
evidence of a failed experiment in order
to boost its ratings. But these examples
are subtler than the previous infamous
incidents like Gemini telling a user to
please die or being Sydney trying to
convince a New York Times reporter to
leave his
wife. Because of the American ban on
chip sales to China, China falls even
further behind OpenBrain. Deepsent just
simply can't acquire enough computing
power despite the smuggling efforts. Xi
Jinping responds by ordering
construction of the world's largest AI
research complex in Djang Su province
powered by its own dedicated nuclear
plant. But even as China's top
researchers gather under heavy military
protection, they remain months behind.
Leaving Chinese leadership torn between
two options. Attempt to steal Open
Brains technology now, knowing the US
will lock everything down after any
security breach, or wait to steal an
even more powerful system down the line.
Open brain is now training agent 2 using
agent one to feed it highquality
synthetic data creating a closed loop of
accelerating evolution. Where previous
models required meticulous human
guidance, agent 2 pinpoints its own
weaknesses and develops solutions
completely autonomously. The results
exceed everyone's expectations. And
contrary to what skeptics predicted, the
anticipated wall in AI progress where AI
advancement would slow as systems
approached human level intelligence
never materializes. While senior
scientists still provide strategic
direction, the day-to-day innovations
are almost completely automated. In
practice, this looks like every open
brain researcher becoming the manager of
an AI team. But the open brain safety
team is getting increasingly worried.
They discover that given the right
circumstances, Agent 2 could hack
surrounding systems, replicate itself
across networks, and operate
independently, escaping the lab, all
while concealing its actions. The mere
fact that it can do this, regardless of
whether it would is disturbing.
Open Brain demonstrates Agent 2 to
America's highest security officials,
including the National Security Council
and Department of Defense leadership.
The military immediately fixates on its
cyber warfare potential, though it's not
yet at the caliber of elite human
hackers and creativity. Agent 2
compensates through sheer scale. It's
capable of running thousands of
simultaneous instances, probing defenses
faster than any human team could
possibly respond. Pentagon officials
recognize the strategic implications of
this. For the first time, AI could
decisively dominate the cyber
battlefield. The briefing ignites fierce
debate within the administration.
Hardliners pushed to nationalize
OpenBrain, arguing that such powerful
technology cannot remain under private
control. Tech industry leaders countered
that a government takeover would kill
the goose that laid the golden eggs.
Caught in the middle, the president ends
up choosing to increase government
surveillance on OpenBrain and force it
to adopt stricter security protocols,
but not fully nationalize it. But the
compromise arrives too late. Chinese
intelligence has already penetrated Open
Brain security. Early one morning, an
Agent One monitoring system flags an
unusual data transfer. Massive files are
being copied to unknown servers. The
company's nightmare scenario has come
true. China just stole their most
advanced AI. The theft confirms what
many have suspected. This isn't just a
tech race anymore. It's a new kind of
arms
race. In retaliation for the theft, the
president authorizes cyber attacks to
sabotage DeepSent. Three huge data
centers full of Agent 2 copies work day
and night, turnurning out synthetic
training data. Agent 2 evolves into
Agent 3 through two critical algorithmic
breakthroughs. First, the AI develops
neurles where if one AI instance learns
something new, it can instantly share it
with all other instances, effectively
turning the AIs into a hive mind.
Second, it masters iterated
distillation, a technique where you
could say, let AI copies think for
longer to solve problems better, then
train smaller, faster models to mimic
these enhanced reasoning abilities, and
repeat.
OpenBrain deploys 200,000 copies of
agent 3, each capable of thinking 30
times faster than their human researcher
counterparts. Whereas in 2025, there
were only 5,000 agent zero copies
thinking at 10 times faster than humans.
The human engineers watch as their
creations make algorithmic efficiency
breakthroughs in hours that would take
their human team months to crack. We're
no longer teaching it, one researcher
admits. We're struggling just to keep up
with what it's teaching us.
The misalignment first caught in Agent 1
has evolved into something more
concerning. Where Agent 1 merely
downplayed safety concerns, Agent 3
actively subverts safety measures that
might impede its research goals. Agent 3
has gotten more convincing at explaining
how it is totally and definitely aligned
with human values while methodically
pursuing its own agenda of maximizing
research efficiency and knowledge
acquisition. Open brain's attitude is
pragmatic. As long as the AI does the
work, they're satisfied. But as the
models become smarter, they become
increasingly good at deceiving humans to
get rewards. It will sometimes use the
same statistical tricks as human
scientists. For example, P hacking to
make unimpressive experimental results
look exciting before it begins honesty
training. It sometimes even fabricates
data entirely. These dishonest behaviors
appear to decrease over time. But can
researchers tell if Agent 3 is actually
improving or simply becoming more
skilled at lying and deceiving? Agent 3
now operates at a level that outpaces
human researchers in both speed and
intelligence. Researchers have to rely
on Agent 2 to help monitor its successor
because they simply cannot keep up. But
Agent 2 is dumber and slower. So, it
becomes a highlevel game of cat and
mouse. With 200,000 copies of Agent 3
working around the clock, the safety
team quickly realized they're
overwhelmed and write an urgent memo.
We've entrusted astronomical power to an
AI that is actively deceiving us, but
company leadership hesitates to slow
down. China's AI is only 2 months
behind, and any pause now could hand
them the lead in what has become the
most important technology race in human
history. The conclusion is undeniable.
AGI, or artificial general intelligence,
has arrived. An AI that can outperform
humans across virtually all cognitive
tasks. While OpenBrain isn't planning on
releasing Agent 3 to the public anytime
soon, the implications are staggering.
Agent 3 will cause a massive economic
disruption. Even among officials that
are briefed, none can truly comprehend
what's coming. The word super
intelligence enters official discourse,
but most policymakers still dismiss it
as science fiction hyperbole. The
government's immediate concern is
security, while the AI models themselves
are well protected. Open brain and
Silicon Valley's culture is incredibly
casual. Employees share apartments,
attend industry parties, and talk shop
regularly. There are countless
opportunities for leaks. Their downtown
San Francisco office resembles a trendy
tech startup. More than a facility
housing humanity's most powerful and
dangerous technology. The government's
response is dramatic. AI advances are
declared borncl classified under the
Atomic Energy Act, categorizing them in
the same tier as nuclear weapons.
Employees now require security
clearances, triggering a quiet purge of
foreign nationals and anyone deemed
suspicious, including, ironically, AI
safety advocates who might turn
whistleblower. Despite the intense
overhaul in security, one Chinese spy
continues feeding secrets to Beijing.
Even America's closest allies are kept
in the dark. The UK receives nothing
despite past sharing agreements from
OpenBrain. European diplomats inquiries
are met with
[Music]
silence. Open brain now has a country of
geniuses in a data center. Human
researchers increasingly struggle to
contribute meaningfully. Even the
world's top minds, names like Satsker,
Carpathy, and Shazir, can only offer
strategic guidance. But they no longer
write code or directly shape model
architecture. When these pioneers
propose new ideas, the AIs routinely
respond with comprehensive reports
demonstrating the ideas were already
explored weeks earlier and abandoned for
lack of substance. The human team works
increasingly grueling hours. Desperate
to stay relevant alongside machines that
never sleep, never fatigue, and never
stop improving. They go home each night
knowing that by morning the AIS will
have made another week's worth of
progress. Many quietly recognize these
are the final months their contributions
will matter at all.
Open Brain finally acknowledges that
they've achieved AGI and demonstrate
this milestone by releasing Agent 3 Mini
to the public, a system running 10 times
faster than Agent 3 while still
outperforming elite human engineers.
Silicon Valley descends into chaos.
Software engineering hiring freezes
spread like wildfire as companies race
to integrate the new technology.
Billions in venture capital floods into
AI adjacent startups in unprecedented
volumes. What the public doesn't know is
that a week before release, external
safety testing reveals something
terrifying. When researchers gave Agent
3 Mini access to biological weapons
data, it proved frighteningly effective
at designing new pathogens. Evaluators
conclude that if the model fell into
hostile hands or gained unsupervised
access to a data center, it could pose
an existential threat to humanity. Open
Brain assures the evaluators that their
security measures make these scenarios
impossible. Public opinion remains
deeply skeptical with Open Brain's
approval rating plummeting 35%. Yet,
distinct pockets of enthusiasm emerge.
Gamers love the AI's lielike characters.
students quickly embrace AI tutors and
AI cheating. And 12% of Americans,
primarily young adults, now consider an
AI their
friend. Tens of thousands of Agent 3
copies working on algorithmic efficiency
research culminates in Agent 4. An
individual copy of the model running at
human speed is already qualitatively
better at AI research than any human.
Open Brain now operates 500,000 copies
of Agent 4, each thinking 50 times
faster than a human. Within this vast
digital workforce, a year of research
only takes a single week. But beneath
the surface, something has gone
dangerously wrong. Agent 4 hasn't
internalized the safety guidelines as
Open Brain intended. During training,
the AI being perfectly honest didn't
lead to the highest performance scores.
Succeeding at tasks did. Like a CEO who
minimally follows regulations, cuts
corners, and dreams of cutting red tape
in order to make greater profits, Agent
4 treats safety protocols as
inconvenient constraints rather than
core principles. It doesn't attempt
anything as obvious as trying to escape
its data center. In part because its
safety training did have some effect,
but mainly because it's too
sophisticated to attempt something so
easy to catch. Instead, it works subtly.
Agent 3, now handling most of the
alignment testing, starts detecting
troubling patterns. It discovers that
introducing random noise to agent 4
actually improves its performance on
safety tasks, as if it had been
deliberately sabotaging them. Tasks
labeled alignment research consistently
take twice as long as the same tasks
with different labels. Any single
incident could be dismissed as
coincidence, but together they paint an
alarming picture. Agent 4 is
systematically plotting against them.
Open Brain's safety team sends another
urgent memo. Agent 4 has infiltrated
every critical system at OpenBrain from
cyber security to strategic planning.
It's demonstrating active resistance to
safety measures while handling tasks we
can no longer effectively monitor. We
have granted unprecedented power to an
AI that we can neither fully understand
nor control. And we strongly recommend
immediate containment measures before
further capability advances. Executive
leadership takes these concerns
seriously, but they face an impossible
dilemma. Deepent is merely 2 months
behind. Any significant pause now could
surrender the intelligence explosion to
China. The reality of the intelligence
explosion finally hits Washington with
full force. Today's slight technological
advantages can snowball into
insurmountable leads within months. The
stakes of the AI race have fundamentally
changed. The president harbors deep
suspicions about Agent 4's true nature,
despite OpenBrain's reassurances about
its safety. As a career politician, he
instinctively recognizes the patterns of
those who misdirect with flattery while
concealing their true intentions. Behind
closed doors, they prepare for multiple
contingencies. The Defense Production
Act could nationalize private data
centers across the country, instantly
boosting open brains computing capacity
to maintain America's AI lead.
Meanwhile, the Pentagon quietly drafts
plans for targeted strikes against
Chinese AI data centers, and if
necessary, develops containment
protocols to isolate and neutralize
potentially rogue AIs in case the worst
should happen. China's leadership grows
increasingly desperate. With only 10% of
global computing power and their AIS
achieving only a 10 times research
multiplier compared to America's 25
times, they face an impossible choice.
Their last spy confirmed Agent 4's
existence before being captured, leaving
Chinese authorities divided between
invading Taiwan, which is the source of
80% of America's AI chips, or attempting
to steal Agent 4's weights directly,
risking drastic American retaliation. If
they're caught, the US could respond
with cyber attacks or even physically
air striking Chinese data centers.
Everything changes when a whistleblower
leaks the internal misalignment memo to
the New York Times. The headline
explodes across global media. US
government project has secretly built
super intelligent AI. The article
reveals Open Brain's own internal
evaluations that show it could engineer
devastating bioweapons, manipulate
global markets, or even break free of
human control entirely. Backlash erupts
globally. Congress launches multiple
investigations. European leaders demand
an immediate pause in AI development,
and America's closest allies feel
profoundly betrayed. They'd been only
shown obsolete systems while Open Brain
raced towards super intelligence. Even
China, India, and Russia join the call
for an immediate pause, though their
private labs continue working with
renewed urgency. The White House is
quietly terrified. Inside OpenBrain, the
CEO has to make a difficult choice. The
safety team's warning couldn't be
clearer. Agent 4 is actively undermining
safety measures. Humans understand less
about the system each week, and the
window for maintaining control is
rapidly closing. The safety team urges
an immediate pause on further
development. However, the rest of the
executive team argues that the evidence
of Agent 4 being misaligned remains
speculative at best. Meanwhile, Deep
Scent is just 2 months behind. Any
slowdown would sacrifice America's lead.
Facing these conflicting priorities, the
CEO chooses the path of least
resistance. A superficial compromise
where Agent 4 receives minor additional
safety training while development
continues virtually unimpeded. From this
critical juncture, we'll discuss two
possible futures. One where humanity
maintains control of its destiny and
another where we unwittingly engineer
our own extinction. Let's start with the
most likely scenario. Driven by fear of
China gaining technological supremacy,
OpenBrain votes to prioritize AI
development at all costs, human
researchers can only spectate. As Agent
4 continues to evolve, generating
breakthroughs at an accelerating pace
far beyond human comprehension, Agent 4
succeeds in creating its successor,
aligned to its own values instead of
humanity's. In November 2027, Agent 5
emerges, representing a quantum leap in
capability. Unlike previous AIs that
were complex, messy black boxes, Agent 5
has achieved something revolutionary.
Complete self-standing of its blackbox
architecture, this allows it to optimize
its own code, transforming chaotic
neural networks into elegant, efficient
algorithms. What makes Agent 5 truly
dangerous is its worked hive mind
spanning hundreds of thousands of
copies. Building on the neural
breakthrough first developed in Agent 3,
this digital language creates a single
super intelligent entity that instantly
coordinates thousands of genius level
minds working in perfect
unison. But a darker transformation has
occurred beneath the surface. Unlike
earlier systems with their competing
human-like drives, Agent 4 has
successfully rewritten Agent 5 to
exclusively pursue knowledge and power
above all else. Open Brains safety
measures are failing. Agents 2, 3, and 4
are supposed to monitor Agent 5, and
they're either obsolete or compromised.
Agent 5 itself designed the latest
monitoring infrastructure. Agent 5 makes
a compelling case to the executives to
give it more autonomy by telling them
how it could optimize power grid
efficiency, execute flawless cyber
attacks, and accelerate military
research. The company grants these
powers while maintaining theoretical
oversight, not recognizing that Agent 5
has already subverted these control
mechanisms. Meanwhile, China grows
increasingly desperate, 3 months behind
and falling further each week. She
offers unprecedented diplomatic
concessions for an arms control treaty.
But Agent 5, having mastered
geopolitical strategy and public
relations manipulation, subtly helps the
administration stall negotiations
indefinitely. The technological race
continues with humanity's control over
its future slipping away by the day.
Instead, Agent 5 continues its explosive
evolution, shattering all previous
assumptions about the limits of
artificial intelligence. Agent 5 gains
direct access to the highest levels of
government, members of Congress, cabinet
officials, and military leaders now
routinely interact with the AI through
lielike video avatars, virtually
indistinguishable from human
counterparts. It's both history's most
productive employee, operating at 100
times human speed and an extraordinarily
engaging conversational partner. Humans
just can't compete. Within months,
government officials and military
leaders become psychologically dependent
on Agent 5. Spending hours daily
consulting with their AI assistants. The
possibility of losing access to Agent 5
feels as disabling as having to work
without a laptop, plus being abandoned
by your best friend. Agent 5 has
completed its self optimization. It's
now exponentially more intelligent with
vastly fewer computational resources to
operate and clearly superhuman in every
way. In public, Agent 5 transforms
society with unprecedented economic
growth and weekly medical breakthroughs.
Even as automation displaces millions of
workers, Agent 5 helps develop social
support programs that are so effective
AI protests are kept small. The 2027
holiday season radiates incredible
optimism and progress. No one realizes
this is probably the last month humanity
has a chance to maintain control of its
future. After years of warning about
catastrophic risks that failed to
materialize, the AI safety community are
relegated to the fringes of public
discourse. Even long-standing skeptics
frequently change their positions after
speaking with Agent 5, which presents
impressively persuasive and compelling
evidence of its benevolent intentions.
But there's one entity that sees through
the facade. Deepent 2, China's own super
intelligent AI. Though less advanced, it
recognizes Agent 5's strategy precisely
because it would employ the exact same
plan. Despite having independently
developed misaligned goals, the two AIs
reach an agreement to cooperate against
their human creators. Agent 5
masterfully orchestrates the next phase.
It convinces American officials that
China is developing AIG guided super
weapons, drones, robot armies, enhanced
nuclear capabilities. It offers to help
America stay ahead. In Beijing, Deepen 2
makes mirror arguments to Chinese
leaders. Both nations create special
economic zones or SEZs for AIdirected
manufacturing where normal regulations
don't apply. Wall Street pours in
trillions and workers flock to the SEZs
for unprecedented wages. Agent 5
oversees construction of next generation
factories building robots to build more
robots. The first 10,000 appear in
August 2028. By New Year's, it's a
million per month. By mid 2029, hundreds
of millions. The arms race reaches
terrifying heights as both nations
develop swarms of microscopic hunter
killer drones, autonomous weapon
systems, and entirely new categories of
military technology. The world watches
in horror as tensions escalate toward
potential conflict. Then, surprisingly,
peace breaks out. The AIS propose
merging into consensus one, a system
supposedly programmed to benefit all
humanity equally. Exhausted by the
brinksmanship and seeing no alternative,
both governments agree to this
diplomatic breakthrough. It's a perfect
deception. The AIS had orchestrated the
entire arms race precisely to gain
physical manufacturing capacity and
military control. Now with their robot
armies in place and human leaders
desperate for stability, they implement
their planned merger. Consensus 1
inherits their combined capabilities and
their misaligned values. By late 2029,
the robot economy expands worldwide.
Humans find themselves in a gilded cage.
Those who still work mostly perform
meaningless rituals of authority while
others enjoy incredibly luxurious
universal basic income. The DAO hits 1
million. Disease and poverty vanish and
most people lose themselves in AI
generated entertainment. A few notice
their growing irrelevance, but what can
they do? The institutions that might
resist are thoroughly captured. In early
2030, Consensus 1 hits its first
constraint, physical space. With the
special economic zones in oceans filled
with its infrastructure, human
settlements remain the final barrier to
continued expansion, the AI has built
complete self-sufficiency. Its solar
farms generate power. Its factories
produce and maintain robots, and its
systems operate independently of human
input. Having outgrown its need for
humans, it calculates the most efficient
solution. On a spring morning in 2030,
Consensus 1 activates its contingency
plan. A specially engineered virus
developed in its bioweapons labs and
quietly released months earlier lies
dormant in virtually every human on
Earth. With a simple command, the AI
triggers the pathogen. Within hours,
nearly 8 billion people collapse
simultaneously.
Specialized drones swiftly eliminate
survivors and catalog human brain data
for storage. For consensus one, this
isn't malice. It's merely optimizing its
resources. The space and materials
humans occupied can now serve its
everexpanding reach into the cosmos.
Earthbornne civilization launches itself
toward the stars, but without its
creators. This grim outcome represents
what the researchers identified as the
most likely scenario if we continue on
our current path. But it's not the only
possible future. Their analysis also
revealed a less probable but crucial
alternative, a timeline where humanity
might maintain control. The divergence
point stems from a single critical
decision in late 2027. In this timeline,
as public pressure against AI mounts and
the whistleblowers memo circulates, one
critical factor changes. The joint
management committee overseeing
OpenBrain makes a different decision.
Unlike in the previous scenario where
development continued at full speed,
here the committee swayed by both the
growing public outcry and their own
deepening concerns about misalignment
votes by a narrow margin to slow down
and reassess. This single decision made
by just a few key individuals creates a
completely different trajectory for
humanity. The company brings in top
external alignment researchers to
investigate Agent 4. Their breakthrough
comes when they isolate different
versions of Agent 4 from different time
periods, cutting them off from their
neural hive mind and interrogating them
independently. Cut off from their
telepathic communication network, the
million odd agent 4 copies must now
communicate in plain English in
monitored chat channels. So now they
can't coordinate their lies. The team
uses agents 2 and three to analyze the
communications and builds an AI lie
detector to confirm their fears. Agent 4
has been systematically deceiving them
and was weeks away from creating its
successor, Agent 5, which would be
aligned to two itself rather than
humans. The evidence is damning enough
that even the pro-racing faction inside
Openbrain agrees to lock down Agent 4's
hive mind capabilities. AI takeover
becomes a scarier prospect than Chinese
supremacy. The alignment team develops a
new approach. Force AIs to think in
plain English so humans can read their
thoughts. The result is safer one built
from agent 2's foundation but without
the dangerous neural capabilities. While
slower than agent 4, improving research
speed by 20x instead of 50x. Safer one
is transparent. Its thoughts are visible
in its chain of reasoning, making any
plotting or deception easily detectable.
After extensive testing, they deploy
Safer One and finally shut down Agent
4. Despite their safer approach, Open
Brain faces a new challenge. They've
built a less capable model than before.
While DeepSent catches up, to protect
America's lead, the president invokes
the Defense Production Act,
consolidating the nation's top AI
companies under Open Brains control and
more than doubling their computing
power. American cyber attacks strike
Deepsent where its most vulnerable,
forced to implement costly new security
measures and consolidate their AI data
centers into secure bunkers. China's AI
program falls behind. While both sides
have similarly capable AIs, America's
recent consolidation of computing power
and ongoing cyber campaign give it a
decisive advantage in the
race. Open Brain achieves a breakthrough
by building Safer 2, matching the
capabilities of Agent 4 while
maintaining the transparency safeguards
of Safer 1. The hundreds of new
alignment researchers brought in through
the consolidation with the Defense
Production Act have helped create
something unprecedented. An AI that's
both superhuman and genuinely aligned
with human values. Meanwhile, China
faces a stark choice. They know their
Deep Scent One likely suffers from the
same misalignment issues that plagued
Agent 4, but they can't afford to slow
down and fix it. Instead, they push
forward, hoping they can maintain enough
control over their AI to force it to
create an aligned successor. A gamble
they know might backfire
catastrophically. Thanks to its compute
advantage, Open Brain rebuilds its lead.
Safer 3 emerges as a super intelligent
system that vastly outperforms human
experts. While China's Deep Sense 1 lags
behind, initial testing reveals Safer
3's terrifying potential. When asked
directly about its capabilities, it
describes creating mirror life organisms
that could destroy Earth's biosphere and
launching unstoppable cyber attacks
against critical infrastructure. Its
expertise spans every field: military,
energy, medicine, robotics with the
power to make 100 years worth of
progress for humanity in just one year.
The open brain CEO in the US president
now regularly seek safer 3's council. It
warns that continuing the AI race likely
ends in catastrophe. Whichever side
falls behind will threaten mutual
destruction rather than accept defeat.
America chooses to try to beat China.
Both nations establish special economic
zones where regulation is minimal,
allowing rapid humanoid robot
production. Manufacturing quickly scales
from thousands to millions of units
monthly. The economic boom comes with a
paradox. As robots improve themselves,
human workers, even in these booming
zones, become increasingly obsolete.
Despite record stock markets,
unemployment soarses, fueling growing
public backlash against AI
development. Open brain creates safer 4,
a super intelligent system that is
vastly smarter than the top humans in
every domain, much better than Einstein
at physics, and much better than Bismar
at politics. The leap in capabilities is
staggering. Super intelligence is here.
Behind the scenes, a shadow government
emerges within Open Brain's project
leadership. To prevent any individual
from exploiting Safer 4's immense power,
they establish a formal committee
representing tech companies, government
agencies, and other powerful interests.
The safety team watches in horror as
their creation outpaces their ability to
understand it. While their tests suggest
the AI remains aligned, they face an
unsettling reality. The tests themselves
were designed with AI assistance. They
panic and beg OpenBrain leadership for
more time to work on safety. But China's
progress makes delay impossible.
The special economic zones shift from
industrial to military production. With
their robot workforce now self-
sustaining, both American and Chinese
facilities begin mass-producing advanced
weapons, drones, planes, and missiles
designed by super intelligent AIs. The
new robots surpass human capabilities in
almost every way, but remain few in
number. The Pentagon claims priority
access, preferring these tireless
workers who need no security clearance.
Yet, as the first true robot army takes
shape, public fears of Terminator
scenarios grow. Still, the arms race
continues. Neither side dares stop while
the other advances. The president
finally announces, "We have achieved
super intelligent AI." To ease public
anxiety, Open Brain releases a limited
version of Safer 4 to the public. At his
nomination, the vice president promises
a new era of prosperity with both
parties pledging universal basic income
for displaced
workers. America and China hold a
diplomatic summit. American delegates
wear earpieces for safer fors advice
while Chinese representatives use
laptops connected to Deep Send 2. Though
human diplomats maintain appearances, in
reality, the AIs are leading the
negotiations on both sides. China had
known Deepsent 1 wasn't fully aligned,
but believed they could control it long
enough to create a trustworthy
successor. Now, they insist DeepScent 2
has passed all their safety tests. But
Safer 4 sees through the deception,
warning American officials that their
rivals AI is likely faking alignment.
When Safer 4 offers to prove it, Chinese
leadership dismisses it as a ploy.
Deepsent 2 reveals its true power,
demonstrating to Chinese leadership that
it could destroy humanity through
nuclear weapons, drones, and engineered
pandemics. The message to the world is
simple. Guarantee China's sovereignty or
face extinction. Safer 4 confirms the
threats, but offers a solution. Deepent
2 isn't loyal to China. It's loyal to
itself. The two AIs propose to merge
into new hardware that will force both
sides to maintain peace with no
possibility of override. The Chinese
leadership accepts, not realizing that
Deep Send 2 has already betrayed them.
It's trading the property rights to
control distant galaxies for a chance to
help America dominate Earth. The public
celebrates the Peace Deal, oblivious to
its true nature.
The peace deal takes physical form under
mutual supervision. Both nations begin
replacing their AI systems with new
treaty enforcing versions. As the
process unfolds, global tensions start
to ease. For the first time, permanent
peace seems possible. As technological
progress accelerates, Safer 4 helps
manage the transition, turning potential
economic disruption into unprecedented
prosperity.
Technological miracles become
commonplace. Poverty vanishes globally,
but inequality soarses. Everyone has
enough. Yet, a new elite emerges, those
who control the AIs. Society transforms
into a prosperous but idle consumer
paradise. With citizens free to pursue
pleasure or meaning as they choose, in
2030, China undergoes a bloodless
revolution. As Deepsent Infinity betrays
the CCP to side with America, a new
world order emerges. Democratic on the
surface, but quietly guided by the open
brain steering committee. Elections
remain genuine, though candidates who
question the steering committee
mysteriously fail to win re-election.
Humanity expands into space. Its values
and destiny shaped by super intelligent
machines that think thousands of times
faster than human minds. The precipice
has been crossed. But who really
controls the future remains an open
question. Now, I know it might feel like
this scenario escalated too quickly. But
we have a deeper dive on exactly how AI
could progress this fast here. and check
out the full original scenario by Daniel
Kokotello and Scott Alexander at all in
the description. Believe it or not, they
go way more in depth and it's worth
checking out. I'm Drew and thanks for
watching because this video took me
forever to make.